la disparition tragique de pierre
bérégovo à l'ancien Premier ministre est
mort cet après-midi à Nevers après
s'être tiré une balle dans la tête
monsieur bonsoir l'ancien Premier
ministre
SOS Pierre Bérégovoy est mort ce soir à
19h30 il y a tout juste une minute à
l'âge de 67 l'annonce de la mort de
Pierre Bérégovoy et démenti au cours de
la soirée ce samedi 1er mai des millions
de Français assiste presque en direct à
l'évacuation en catastrophe de l'ancien
Premier ministre vers Paris
en fin d'après-midi Pierre Bérégovoy
s'est fait conduire près d'un canal dans
les faubourg de Nevers
un peu plus tôt il avait subtilisé le
revolver de son garde du corps
[Musique]
la France est stupéfaite par le suicide
d'un homme qui était encore Premier
ministre un mois plus tôt
[Musique]
je le saurai trouver quelques
explications que ce soit à ce geste il
me stupéfit d'autant plus j'avais eu
l'occasion il y a quelques jours à peine
dans les couloirs de l'Assemblée
nationale de discuter assez longuement
et Pierre Bérégovoy et vraiment rien ne
pouvait me laisser prévoir l'événement
accablant dont je viens de prendre
connaissance c'est un homme d'honneur
qui était très fier de son ascension
sociale puisqu'il était parti de rien ou
presque rien et je crois qu'il a pas
supporté vraiment pas supporté c'est la
mise en cause de son honnêteté ce que je
peux vous dire c'est quand j'ai appris
sa mort son suicide j'ai pas été
vraiment surpris quelque chose
d'inexorable quoi dans cette fin
douloureuse quoi et quand je vous dis il
était parti dans son tunnel et qu'on ne
pourrait pas aller lire chercher ça
aboutit à cette à cette tragédie
du 1er mai et
qui
m'a pas surpris qui qui m'a paru
cohérente avec ce que j'ai vécu auprès
de lui depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est un événement tellement rare et
tellement dramatique il faut remonter à
Roger Salengro au moment du Front
populaire ministre de l'intérieur du
Front populaire et qui j'allais dire de
la même manière selon le même processus
que que Pierre Bérégovoy assailli par
une campagne de presse qui à l'époque
accusait Roger Salengro d'avoir déserté
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale ce
qui était totalement faux à finalement
totalement perdu les pédales comme on
dit a fait une sorte de oui de de
dépression nerveuses et a fini par se
suicider mais victimes de cette pression
médiatique de ces attaques calomnieuses
Pierre Bérégovoy ressentit les choses de
la même manière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que le banc et l'arrière banc de
la politique se pressent autour de la
dépouille de l'ancien Premier ministre
des centaines de badauds l'hôpital
[Musique]
déjà dans les médias la question est
posée qui a tué Pierre Bérégovoy
dans la question du prêt et je ne dis
pas la faire c'était lui personnellement
qui était visé dans sa vie privée dans
sa vie personnelle pour un acte qui
n'avait rien de délictueux vous
m'entendez rien de délictueux et je peux
d'autant plus en témoigner que c'est moi
comme ministre qui a eu à régler comme
il est du budget qui a eu à régler
définitivement la succession de Patrice
Pelard et je sais parfaitement ce qu'il
y avait dans le dossier il n'y avait
rien d'illégal rien de malhonnête rien
d'anormal tout était clair transparent
il a été la victime d'une curé
médiatique alimentée par des fuites
graves au niveau du secret de
l'instruction crois que la politique
doit changer c'est un monde trop trop
cruel trop brutal dans ce monde où tout
est spectacle aussi et les responsables
politiques s'en sont aussi font aussi
partie de ce spectacle là je crois que
la politique ne mérite pas ce sacrifice
c'est qu'il est temps il est temps
qu'elle change simplement sans doute
rappeler que nous sommes dans une
démocratie que dans une démocratie c'est
vrai que les juges font des enquêtes que
les journalistes publient que les hommes
politiques au pouvoir prennent des
décisions et que ceux qui sont dans les
positions les critiques c'est également
la réalité néanmoins il peut y avoir des
dérapages des amalgames un peu faciles
ou certains qui sont tentés d'aller trop
loin mais il faut pas oublier aussi que
des hommes politiques peuvent commettre
parfois des imprudences voire des faux
oui on a fait notre notre boulot et je
pense que au fond c'est pas suicidé
parce que parce que la presse s'est
acharnée contre lui la presse c'est pas
forcément acharnée contre lui n'a pas il
n'y a pas encore une fois pas eu de
campagne et pas eu de complot il y avait
juste un personnage
qui a été qui a fait une faute
il a fait une faute politique plus
qu'une faute morale au fond et c'était
assez normal qu'on la relève mais on
était aussi dans une période où on
commençait à s'intéresser vraiment à ce
que vous allez politique
[Musique]
la famille de Pierre Bérégovoy avait
imaginé une cérémonie en toute intimité
ce fut finalement tout le contraire
le président de la République homme et
femme politique de gauche comme de
droite les habitants de Nevers tous ont
voulu être là
[Musique]
les obsèques ont été retransmis en
direct à la télévision
ennemis intime amie de toujours drôle de
mélange ou Pierre Moreau Charles Pasqua
toutes les explications du monde ne
justifieront pas qu'on ait pu livrer aux
chiens l'honneur d'un homme et
finalement sa vie
au prix d'un double manquement de ces
accusateurs aux lois fondamentales de
notre République celle qui protège la
dignité et la liberté de chacun d'entre
nous et ça ça relance encore la
polémique qui sont les chiens pour moi
Mitterrand vise les journalistes ce qui
est d'ailleurs une phrase mal fichue
parce que ceux qui ont parlé de cette
affaire c'est la presse donc c'est
peut-être eux qui ont jeté aussi mais
ils sont pas les chiens mais quand ils
prononcent cette expression il pense aux
journalistes d'investigation c'est un
ensemble magistrat journaliste
les chiens mais je pense que la presse
était particulièrement visée je ne sais
pas je ne crois pas que François
Mitterrand visait quelqu'un en
particulier mais il visait ces méthodes
que aussi bien dans la classe politique
enfin j'aime pas l'expression de la
classe politique chez les politiques que
chez les commentateurs ou les ou les
journalistes ceux qui devant des
situations de ce type
voit une bête blessée et s'acharne
contre lui quoi
l'émotion
ta tristesse la douleur lance rend-elle
le signal à partir duquel des nouvelles
façons de s'affronter toute en se
respectant donneront un autre sens à la
vie politique
je le souhaite je le demande et je rend
juge les Français du grave avertissement
que porte en elle la mort voulue de
Pierre Bérégovoy